parade zum tag des sieges
jedes jahr am 9 mai feiert die russische
armee den triumph über nazi-deutschland
putins macht gründet auch auf dem mythos
der mächtigen und heldenhaften
russischen armee
[Musik]
die zuverlässigsten garanten sind die
tapferen russischen streitkräfte und
natürlich werden wir uns gemeinsam für
die soldaten die entwicklung des landes
und für das wohlergehen der russischen
familien einsetzen
eine kleinstadt im norden russlands
viele familien hier sitzen vor ihren
handys sie suche nach ihren söhnen
mithilfe ukrainischer telegram kanäle
europe hat so ein lebenszeichen gefunden
von ihrem sohn daniel er geriet am 27
februar in ukrainische gefangenschaft
spricht zu deiner familie jetzt hast du
die chance spricht mit ihnen
der nil muster als wehrdienstleistender
kämpfen die familie wusste lange zeit
nicht wo er ist
das ist das erste video von ihm das
allererste
er sagte später wir seien alle
bombardiert worden niemand sei mehr am
leben
diese erste videobotschaft nach vier
monaten militärdienst war der einzige
horror für mich
die mutter hat eine anwältin gebeten ihr
zu helfen sie soll beim
verteidigungsministerium herausfinden wo
genau daniel jetzt ist anruf bei der
hotline
die anwältin muss lange warten auf
wiederhören niemand ist hier für
irgendetwas verantwortlich
noch vor einigen monaten war die familie
stolz dass daniel zum militär ging ein
video von seiner vereidigung bei der
vierten garde panzerdivision einen
vertrag als berufssoldat habe er nicht
unterschrieben sagt die mutter
daniel kämpfte in der nähe von haag in
seiner einheit geriet unter beschuss
viele seiner kameraden starben
militär experten sind sich sicher
wehrpflichtige und junge soldaten sind
für putins armee kanonenfutter
das sind einfach unerfahrene leute die
daran geschickt werden was allerdings
sozusagen ein strukturelement über die
zeiten ist
russland hat sehr viele soldaten und der
einzelne spielt natürlich da auch keine
so große rolle und diese
menschenverachtung die hinter diesem
system und diesem denken steht
die kann man sich nicht brutal genug
vorstellen
der russische wehrdienstleistende daniel
kriegsgefangener sein video vom
ukrainischen telegramm kanal und wie ist
dein name daniel david dein geburtsdatum
november 2001 wie alt warst du bei der
verpflichtung
20 jahren hast du einen vertrag als
berufssoldat nein
mehr als tausend kilometer entfernt
seine familie weiß nicht wann oder ob
daniel wieder nach hause kommt bei
anderen russischen soldaten gibt es
gewissheit sie werden nicht mehr nach
hause kommen sie sind tot gefallen in
putins angriffskrieg zu sehen sind ihre
bilder auf ukrainischen telegram kanälen
sie richten sich an die russischen
familien die sich fragen wo ihre söhne
geblieben sind
wie hier in einem dorf im süden
russlands viele menschen sind arm leben
von der viehzucht wie die familie von
mahmut der im februar gerade 21 jahre
alt geworden ist seine tante stand ihm
sehr nah
niemand wusste wann sie dort ihren tod
finden würden
ich kann ihnen sagen dass vor einer
woche das gerücht im dorf die runde
machte dass ein junge in diesem
telegramm kanal gesehen wurde der mammut
ähnlich sah
die schulkinder sahen das auf dem
telekom kanal
in den örtlichen medien heißt es erst
viel später mahmut starb als held
während einer militärischen sonderaktion
ende februar irgendwo im donbass durch
batterie beschuss geblieben ist nur
seine uniform der gerade 21 jährige war
schütze in einer spezialeinheit erzählt
die familie das letzte mal habe er sich
aus der nähe von cardiff gemeldet
er hat uns vorher noch erzählt dass es
sich um einen sehr ernsten krieg
handelte er hat noch andere dinge
gesehen die er uns nicht gesagt hat sie
wurden in betrügerischer absicht dorthin
gebracht warum haben sie die eltern
nicht informiert warum haben sie uns
nicht bescheid gesagt ich hätte ihn
wahrscheinlich selbst abgeholt
in der gegend von mahmut dorf bangen
weitere familien um ihre söhne 20 andere
junge männer sollen hier ebenfalls
eingezogen worden seien und es werden
nicht die letzten gewesen sein das
russische verteidigungsministerium
ordnet in seiner frühlings rekrutierung
an
vom ersten april bis 15 juli 2022 werden
134 1500 bürger der russischen
föderation im alter zwischen 18 und 27
jahren einberufen
für militärexperten ist klar neue
russische offensiven in der ukraine
brauchen unzählige soldaten
es ist ein altes militärisches prinzip
dass die angriffskraft dreimal so groß
sein muss um einen erfolg zu erzielen
natürlich
ist die russische und auch schon die
sowjetische armee die war natürlich
gedrillt auf diese
fast schon planwirtschaftliches denken
dass man eben mit dem einsatz größter
mittel einfach einen erfolg erzwingt
anfang april berichten internationale
medien über 1500 zurückgelassene leichen
russischer soldaten im gebiet der
ukrainischen stadt nie pro die britische
regierung schätzt dass bislang 15
tausend russische soldaten in der
ukraine gestorben sind die trauer um
ihre gefallenen söhne könnte in russland
bald immer mehr eltern treffen die
anwältin hat mit vielen betroffenen
familien gesprochen
ich verstehe nun die mütter deren kinder
bald zur armee müssen und die mit allen
mitteln versuchen dies zu verhindern
ich verstehe sie sehr gut und mache ihm
keine vorwürfe
denn jetzt ist es in der tat
beängstigend geworden mit branchen immer
mehr tote soldaten immer mehr trauernde
familien das verteidigungsministerium
hat in einem erlass reagiert um die
toten abzuholen dürfen die angehörigen
kostenlos anreisen zitat zwei
familienangehörige erhalten militärische
transport dokumente für die fahrt von
ihrem wohnort zum ort der
identifizierung des soldaten und zurück
für die mutter des gefangen genommenen
daniel kein trost
wir hätten nicht gedacht dass unser kind
in solche schwierigkeiten geraten könnte
ich hoffe dass er vor dem ende des
krieges wieder zu hause ist
er ist in den krieg gezogen er hat
wirklich gehofft alles zu ertragen
aber er hatte angst ich
würde jetzt ein glas wodka trinken aber
da hilft mir auch nicht mehr
bis zur nächsten sieges parade am 9 mai
sind es noch 13 tage 13 tage in putins
angriffskrieg in dem laut einer
russischen studie die meisten gefallenen
soldaten zwischen 21 und 23 jahre alt
sind